what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 8th of november
it's your lucky [__] day the
joint is brought to you by blue chew if
you haven't heard uncle joey talk about
bluetooth before you must have been in
the corner crying about how your dick
don't work anymore i've been talking
about blue chew for two [__] years
now the best you're like joey what is
blue chew it's an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis at a fraction of the
cost you can take it any time day and
night and the process is simple sign up
at bluetooth.com
talk to one of the licensed medical
providers and once you're approved in 10
minutes you'll receive the prescription
within days the best part is it's all
online no doctor's office no pharmacy no
judgment it ships right to your door in
a discreet package nobody knows nothing
now you're asking yourself joey you
don't even know me why do i need blue
chew because this is the time of the
year when you want a sling dick some
people want to sling cheer you want a
sling dick with three [__] hands you
want nobody to be depressed or upset by
your performance so if i told you right
now yeah you could sling dick the
[__] best you're like a regular john
holmes and he
but you could be better you could be
sinking these little [__] [__] to
that when they call you they just tap
out that's what blue chew will give you
confidence a confidence that you'll
never have before and let me tell you
something blue chew is amazing the
tablets are made in the usa they're way
cheaper than a [__] pharmacy and like
i told you who's better than you on new
year's day you'll be sitting there going
look at all these women they're lying
around me they can't even [__] walk
anymore i did my job so if you could
benefit from the extra confidence when
it's time to perform aka sling dick blue
chew can help and they got a special
deal for you try blue chew free with
promo code joey joey what the [__] what
are you talking about free i'm talking
about free just pay 5 for shipping
that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month
absolutely free and as always i want to
thank bluechu for sponsoring the joint
the joint is also brought to you by on
it do not forget
their [__] black friday sale is
coming up alpha brain black label
shroom tech sport and shroom tech immune
my favorite new mood at night when you
want the lights to go out they got an
alpha brain
[__] drink that you could drink right
at the gym they got the listen
anna's doing great things
and you're still [__] around there
i can't get my head together i can't do
this listen it starts with alpha brain
if you don't like it you send it back we
give you the the money back and we don't
even want the product that's how much on
it
believes in alpha brain listen it's
super
charge formula it's gonna make your
mental
[__] focus
you're gonna be laser beaming
[__] you know what i'm saying
you could see right through their
clothes that's how strong your mind is
gonna be
but listen don't take it from me on it's
got a great selection of supplements
weights kettlebells club bats i can't
help you with the club bats or the
kettlebells but i'll get you 10 on any
supplement on that list
do yourself a favor go to honor.com
right now take a look read
up their supplements
whether it's the alpha brain maybe
you're slipping maybe your memory is
going back maybe your father needs to
get his [__]
mind back alpha brain the black label is
going to help them let me tell you
something if you like the alpha brain
alpha brain black label will take you to
places you've never been you're saying
to yourself joe you're sounding a little
bit better today
[Music]
it's the alpha brain black label so do
yourself a favor go to honor.com
learn read
start the the new year off
with a [__] bang right now you should
be prepping for 2022 and how you're
going to take over the [__] world and
let annette be there with you i took
over the world without it so can you how
laser sharp [__] focus you're on it
[__] you understand me you're
looking through walls you can see a coke
rock under the carpet that's the type of
focus i'm talking about so go to
honda.com right now
press in church
joint or joey and get 10 off and it gets
delivered right to your house and you
got to [__] with this no more and it
makes a great [__] christmas gift the
[__] supply chain is going down but
on it is still alive and kicking so go
to honor.com preston church and get 10
off your order delivered right to your
house the joint is also brought to you
by
money
draftkings don't forget tonight you got
pittsburgh
versus the best
holy [__] i don't know what the line is
but [__] draftkings will have it for
you did you see what draftkings did
saturday night they covered boxing they
had [__]
the ufc they had nba they had the world
series last week they do it all but one
thing you never heard me talk about is
the nhl season is underway and draftking
sportsbook has an unbelievable offer to
celebrate the greatest [__] sport on
ice [__] disney on ice draftkings is
going to give you you better dollar than
the nhl game and we're going to give you
a hundred thousand free [__] bets all
right this week the florida is coming up
to see the jersey devils i love [__]
draftkings it's more than just [__]
gambling okay it's piece of [__] mind
that's what i love about them whether
it's the nba college basketball college
football they got it all last night they
had an up booth saturday night on hawaii
versus san diego state plus they have a
social media network on there we could
[__] chit chat on there we'd go
through pics on there draftkings is
tremendous that casino is second to
[__] none they're the official sports
betting partner of the nfl the official
sports betting partner the ufc it
doesn't matter if you're a one-time
clapper or a death deflection however
they like to lamp you [__] win if
sportsbook isn't in your state yet
draftkings won't leave you with your
dick in your hand they got a tremendous
draftkings daily fantasy sports contest
with huge cash prizes all season long
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at a million dollars with
fantasy [__] you you got a great
quarterback show me what you got
draftkings is safe secure and
[__] reliable you understand me
best of all you can withdraw your cash
whenever the [__] you want but let me
tell you something you'll be with
draftkings for years like i've been
they're fantastic i reached out to them
because the service was [__] so great
draftking sportsbook app download it
today use promo code joey throw down one
dollar on any nhl game and win 103 bets
you understand me this week one puck in
the net nets you a big win with promo
code joey at draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
nhl now you got to be 21 older new
jersey indiana pennsylvania only
colorado tennessee new customers only
minimum five dollar deposit and one
dollar wager and
one shot per customer don't [__] around
we're watching you got something
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem
call 1-800 gambler but if you're
straight and you're ready to rock
tonight's tonight right now download the
draftking sportsbook app use promo code
joey
and you got a game tonight with
pittsburgh
against [__]
the bears
the rest is up to you use promo code
joey
and bet a dollar to win 103 bets with
the nhl now if there's nothing else
let's get this [__] party started all
right i'm all talked the [__] out
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday november 8th a beautiful
[__] day to be alive on uncle
joey's joint
representing my little laughing gas
[__] sweatshirt some tremendous
reefer i don't do the laughing gas like
i i can't do the laughing gas every day
i gotta save it for special occasions
you know what i'm saying so like
i can't smoke it every day so i'll smoke
like uh
i rotate weeds
i cannot smoke the same weed every day i
only smoke a joint a day but last week
because [__] the anxiety's going down
i was able to hit it a couple days not
too heavy just a couple hits off the
lion and [__] uh just to get some
appetite you know what i'm saying just
to get some leg kicking nothing in the
morning
just in the afternoon late night i do it
about 10 but
like i said this week there was a few
days there were like
three o'clock i'm like what the [__]
i'm dying to boredom i might as well
[__] dip into the coconut and i'll do
a couple hits off the lion and [__]
uh
i think i did it two days it was great
but it's so weird how i wake up some
mornings and i'm like i got a clear day
today i got to clear a couple hours
maybe i'll smoke in the morning i do not
have the desire
that's that's insane
that just baffles me and that [__] i
gotta tell you something i have not
tried
to freeze pipe bong
but that freeze pipe bubbler
is that the pipe one the one that you
told me or you [__] freeze it and put
it
let me tell you something that bubbler
because usually i roll a joint i put a
little [__] uh
what's that green [__] that you take out
of the weed keith
i i have a keith net so i put some keef
in there and then i roll a joint and
that gets me [__] a little zoom
and then i wait like an hour and a half
of giggles and tv and stupidity and then
right before i go upstairs
i go out and hit three hits on the lion
woof
i'm [__] done every night this one
i'm lying to you [__]
what did i eat last night
last night i just dipped into mercy's
halloween candy i had two bags of baby m
m's the peanut ones oh my god they're
[__] tremendous when you this is what
baffles me about this that i'm getting
stoned now the way i was getting high
like when i was a kid remember when you
were a kid and you had a smoke and you
had to go to 7-eleven and well there was
no 7-elevens you got to go to like a
[__] bodega and get like
chips
[__] the pies the [__] marshmallow
pies the mallow pies chocolate covered
with the whip uh covered with chocolate
with the [__] that whipped cream
that's gonna kill you that's definitely
got cancer [__] in it now you mud pie
that's what they're [__] called a
couple mud pies and [__]
oh my god you know when you when you eat
with the munchies you [__] eat
like i'll tell you the difference like
sunday night last week my my wife called
me she goes we got to meet
some uh kids and parents and [__] meet
me at the diner
i like this [__] dining this diner's
got great [__] food
manila pandina has some [__] great
food the seafood plaid is good the
gyro's sensational the [__] cream of
turkey soup let me tell you something i
haven't had cream of turkey soup like
that since 1984
the berkshire diner bergen line avenue
there was a diner on like 70
second street when we were kids in north
bergen
we would hit that [__] from 1981
to 85. it was either white castles or
something stupid but it was mostly the
berkshire dine on bergen lion avenue and
it was rough jack let me tell you how
rough that diner was i saw a waitress
take a book of matches out one night
like one of the matches you know how the
whole book lights up and she just threw
it into the booth at some guys that were
being [__] loud and noisy in there
there was this black guy when i was a
kid i do not remember his name little
light-skinned brother didn't say much in
fact he was kind of crazy
he would walk around with a long [__]
jacket every night when we were kids we
couldn't figure this guy out he would
just start walking on 88th street we'd
get in the car smoke dope you know
go to a bar and on the way home like two
hours later we'd see this [__]
just walking the streets in this black
little jacket we didn't know what he was
about we had no idea we left them alone
you know even though those days we used
to [__] with people
one day my buddy was making a right turn
you know you you hit a right turn and
it's dark on the street and somebody's
crossing the street not from the corner
but from the middle of the street that's
why you cross
at the green not in between [__]
you don't [__] walk on that when it's
dark
my buddy pelican went and got rested so
i went to make a right turn
and the dude was walking the middle
street roger missed him
by a [__] inch and the guy gave roger
like a dirty look like what the [__] are
you doing so we started yelling at the
guy from the car and the guy's like [__]
you too we didn't know what to expect
from the guy the guy was a little
creepy looking
and then about a year went by and one
night he came into that berkshire diner
there's that [__] creepy dude the
little black dude with the long [__]
jacket on he said something to the
waitress he said something like some
snot smart remark he wasn't sitting in a
booth he was sitting at the counter like
at the counter in a diner drinking like
a shake or something we were watching
from the door and he's arguing with her
he said something to her i swear to god
the waitress picked them up by the
[__] throat this little black guy she
picked them up by the [__] throat and
carried them out his little legs were
going like this i'll never forget that
we were cheering yeah yeah this was a
crazy [__] diner she threw him out
anyway
the guy started coming into tom and
corki's that's a bar we hung out we were
like 19. crazy cocaine bar they had
[__] this uh jukebox the loudest
jukebox in the tri-state area trust me
i'm telling you you had a headache when
you went in there and they would play
looks to kill by motley crue over and
over and over and i love that jam till
this day every time motley crew comes on
the looks to kill the [__] car speeds
up 10 points i'm up the [__] 90. [__]
sammy hagar yeah i can't drive 55. as
soon as i hear like a song i like like
from the old days like aerosmith last
child i [__] do 90. that's it you
ain't [__] i'm like that dude from
the raiders that were doing 156 in the
corvette that stupid [__] he's
never they're gonna put that bastard
under the [__] jail i mean i feel bad
for him
i feel bad for the family or the girl
that died but holy [__] 156 miles an
hour
they're gonna put you under the [__]
jail and you know what man that is one
thing that you should all worry about
all you drinking and driving
[__] let me tell you how it
goes down
when i got to prison when i got locked
up
yeah there was a guy's in there for
assault and robbery and bank robbery and
all that federal [__] but let me tell
you what was the number one growing
trend in there that i saw
driving drinking and driving
people who would vehicular homicide that
[__]
that [__] was growing up a storm in 88
87. when i got to camp george west
it's a camp so you have to go there if
you have light points like they don't
they send people to a camp who have
light points
and people that have had long sentences
and they've worked themselves down they
haven't been a problem
at the prison so they'll send them to a
camp and that it helps with their uh you
know going out into the real [__]
world i don't know what they call it
whatever the [__] it is
so
what's that talking about who the [__]
knows uh
you know the transition into being in
the street but one of them like they had
to be
out of 90 something convicts 100
convicts
there had to be 12 kids
that were in there for prison now let me
tell you what the [__]
prerequisite was for these kids what
they all shared
number one they were all white
number two they were all in college
and number three they were under the age
of 24.
that's [__] scary when you murder
somebody under the age of 24
and all let me tell you what all those
12 guys had
they weren't heavies
they weren't tough guys they weren't
even [__] like they were very sweet
guys that had made a [__] mistake
they had been caught up you know for
some people it's weed for some people
it's coke for some people it's pills
you know for him it was alcohol and he
[__] made a mistake he was a kid i
became good friends with one of the kids
because he worked in the kitchen
as a matter of fact i took him under my
wing in a way like protection-wise
because i knew like a lot of people were
giving him a hard time so when he
checked into the jail and i
i became an attorney in the jail believe
it or not like one of those dudes that
helps out people when they get in
trouble
and when those guys come in
that guy one of one of the things i have
to do
is go to the orientation process and
welcome them in and explain to them
the [__] point system and the kite
system you know kites is kites is
another word for a [__] request
or like a [__] note they'll say ride
a kite you know i don't want people to
get insulted going joy was saying
whatever so you have to write a kite so
i have to explain something about
writing kites and [__] like that and
then they tell me what they were in
there for and i try to put them in the
right group or whatever like you know
hey or n.a or [__] uh they had like
conan whatever the [__] that is al-anon
i forget what it is all great programs
but i would have to talk them through
that and tell them to go what night the
meetings and [__]
but some of these kids were just they
were scared they were [__] petrified
and i had to talk him off the leg like
am i going to get raped in here the one
kid kept asking me am i going to get
raped in him am i going to and i felt so
[__] bad from that nobody's going to
rape you kid
and if anybody bothers you let us know
and then what we would do when somebody
was a little weaker
antoine spencer the guy in the chicken
hawk the toughest guy in the [__]
prison
the black dude that stabbed the
[__] i would talk to him and go
chicken this guy
is uh you know he's having problems he's
this is not his world
and chicken would get them a job in the
kitchen and watch them and let people
know
that they were chicken and nobody would
give you a [__] hard time so if
you're thinking of drinking and driving
don't that's one thing dog i don't
[__] do
at all
i'm a [__] outlaw i'm a [__]
criminal
my mind is that of a [__] a jackal
but i'll tell you what you go in my
[__] car there's no rolling papers
there's no reefer there's always a
lighter
listen you always got to have a light
all right there's a light there's two
lighters in my [__] car because you
always you know i'm saying something
happens you pull over you want to light
a [__] fire or you know yeah you get
pulled over whatever you got a flat tire
you you know you ever get a [__] flat
tie on the turnpike and jersey carters
are going by you're doing 90. that's not
[__] pretty and your mind goes into
weird thoughts so you light something on
fire so people know you're there and
they'll drive around because if you
think a cone's going to help you how
many people have gotten killed when a
cone's around that [__] don't deter
nobody you let a fire on the [__]
side of the road people go i'm getting
the [__] out of that dog i've done it
before i've lit fires [__] you you ever
been out there changing a [__] tire
one time i went to a denver nugget game
me and a buddy of mine and we were
[__] up not [__] up but like we were
like you know in a rush to get there
and we were flying it was black ice and
i had an acura and my [__] car hit
the black ice and i [__] hit the the
turnstile whatever [__] you call it in
the middle of the street and i had to
put a spare on it like a banana tie
dog those cars were whizzing behind me
you know like when a car whizzes by you
and the whole car shakes and [__] i'm
trying to change the flat it's windy out
i go [__] this i'm killing two birds
with one stone i had like a blanket in
the back that i used to use when i went
on the road and [__] like that [__] it i
lit that [__] on fire
within three minutes i had everybody
there the fire department the police
department triple a
they asked me who to fire who lit the
fire got no [__] idea who lit the
fire all i know is i need help with this
[__] flat i'm sitting in the car
they're out there jacking me the [__] up
the fire department you think i'm
[__] kidding you know me dog i always
i'm prepared you got to be prepared put
a blanket back there some [__] wood
if you look in the trunk of my [__]
subaru i'll tell you what you see back
there you see some hooded sweatshirts
some gloves
some [__] waters just in case you
break down i got some cat food i got
some dog food i got a cat collar i got a
dog collar i got all the essentials in
case you bump into a dog or a cat you
got to bring them [__] home you'll
bump into a dog and this is why i
brought the collar you ever bump into a
[__] dog and he's okay like you pet
him and [__] and people like we don't he
needs help and you're like
me no hablo you're like a [__]
immigrant i don't [__] know
you ever leave and when you come home
you're like [__] i should have taken
that dog now i feel guilty the dog is
out there all night he could have got
hit by a car [__] that so now i see a
dog i see a cat i got a [__] collar
one night i went to this lesbian bar in
long beach to do comedy like 10 years
ago and on the way in there was a
[__] cat i'm under a car i'm like
what the [__] i got to get the cat from
under the car so i got on my hands and
knees i'm out there the whole lgbt
community came out to [__] help me
let me tell you something if you got a
cat stuck in a tree [__] the fire
department you call lbgtq they get there
within minutes they got ladders
tambourines flashlights let me tell you
something they helped me get that
[__] cat from under there the lbgt
community shows up prepared jack
they were lesbians a couple [__] in
there they didn't give a [__] they came
out we jacked up that [__] car i got
that scared kitten out of there and they
[__] helped me drive them down well
you think i'm aces with the lgbt
community i got [__] you know my
my jimmy runs deep in that community no
i don't [__] around i got love for him i
ain't no dave chappelle i'm not here to
break the [__] balls and [__] if you
want to switch governments that's your
priority that's you know what i'm saying
you're like bobby brown when it comes to
that [__] what do i give a [__] yeah
it's your prerogative what do i give a
[__] you want to switch governments
that's got nothing to do with uncle joey
it's a monday you know i'm saying it's a
monday [__] you got to come out
the [__] back you got to come out the
gate swinging on a [__] monday you
guys thought that i was gonna i was some
laid down sally suck my [__] dick i
was having some problems when i got here
but i'm back [__] in full effect when
i jerk off fire comes out now it's over
you [__] thought i was dead and
buried you gave up on the wrong
[__] [__]
you gave up on the wrong [__]
uncle even when i'm dead i'm not going
to be dead even when they pronounce me
dead and put what put me in the casket
and put me six feet under you're still
gonna hear [__] from joey diaz and guess
what you're still gonna think of [__]
joey dears joey diaz ain't going nowhere
for a long [__] time i moved i
[__] uh you know went into a [__]
slump after 20 years 30 years i went
into a slump it happens and it's
accepted now i'm ready i'm back the
anxiety is gone my toenail is [__]
still there let me tell you something
i've been i've been i did this whole
therapy thing on my toenails this year
right i started january 1st
right before the [__] surgery i took
tea tree oil i bought like a case of tea
tree oil that's the only thing that
kills this [__] toad [__] [__]
and i cleaned up my toes and every day
when i take a shower when i come out of
the shower i dry my feet off really good
and i put the tea tree all on it and i
rub coconut oil on my feet i do all this
[__] this is what i'm saying to you it's
tough being me i just don't wake up and
you see this beautiful [__] face i
got i gotta wash hair i gotta [__]
you know put gel in it i gotta put
visine in my eyes it's not what it used
to be that i could just get in the
shower
and get the [__] out and i'm out there
doing what i was doing no more so i
started this on the first and i'm swear
to god to all you [__] you know
i stick to my [__]
every day twice a day three times a day
when i go to jiu jitsu i take a shower
when i get i take a shower before i go
to jiu jitsu put that [__] on my feet
and when i get home and i put a tea tree
all on my toes i do it right i pick up
the [__] nail let me tell you
something
i'm about to give the [__] up i'm going
into 11 months here and yeah the nail
has gone down a little bit and the
[__]
but
holy [__] it's
i don't know what i'm going to do you
suppose when you have when you have a
[__] up toenail you're supposed to
take this pill and it zaps the inside of
you and it zaps all the fungi in your
body i got no fungi in my body i took
the medication but for them to give you
the strong pill they got to do a [__]
blood test on you and test your [__]
kidneys to make sure that your kidney
will hold the medication because it just
cleans the [__] it just zaps you the
[__] out so
i can't take the pill because my kid
needs a compromise
40 years of doing drugs you're gonna
have some [__] back you know you're
gonna have some backlash you're not
going to be able to do everything so i
went with the tea tree oil i got to be
honest 11 [__] months
it's worked a little bit like me and my
buddy did it together my mercy's
godfather has got an ingrown toenail so
we have like a contest who the [__]
gonna get rid of the ingrown uh fungi
toenail first
so we talk like three times a week we
talk about the fungi toenail and [__] he
told me about a month ago he's like
listen die
that's what my friends call me die short
for diaz
listen die i'm thinking [__] uh a
pack and then this [__] ain't working
like oh james you got to give a [__]
you got to give it time you know you got
to go to
you got to cut the nail you got to go to
cvs and buy the buffer and put it on
high speed and buff out your [__] let
me tell you something i got this [__]
chair
you know like your father had you know
you sit back it's a recliner i [__]
earned it okay it's been [__] 58
years i earned the [__] little archie
bunker recliner
so it's got oh my god it's brown
and it's starting to stink between the
ass and the feet it's starting to kick
so i wipe it down you know me though i
clean my [__] you gotta take care of
your [__]
so
every couple nights i [__] buff out
the toenail you know i buff out there's
like three toenails on one foot to that
fungi and there's like three and a half
on the other foot i got the over on the
other toe my left out the fourth toe is
starting to get it and [__] so
what i do first i gotta let my feet
[__] dry and then i gotta [__]
buff them out so i get the maximum you
know whatever so when i buff out the
toenail
the toe dust
goes all over the [__] place and i
wipe it down with the
the lysol
and i put another lysol thing and i
throw it away
little did i know when you [__] hit
that thing
it [__] you know like it's like a
[__] well
so my wife says to me by the way
i looked in one of the creases the other
day when you open up that uh chair
when it opens up there's a part like at
the three quarter where the seams
uh separate from each other and you can
see that there's stuff in there like you
know like a little weed
maybe like a toenail like a cut toenail
maybe there's like a piece of the seed
like a salt from a bagel and [__] like
that but if you look in
you could see a fine line like a half a
gram of toenail dust in there oh my god
it's turned black it's so [__]
disgusting
so my wife vacuumed it out the other day
so we were [__] goofing around she's
like i had to vacuum out your toenail
[__] dust
from the [__] seat so
yeah i gotta start buffing my toenails
outside
but my toenails have me at my last hair
that's what i'm trying to say they're my
last [__] hair patience i'm gonna
give it another two months then i'm
gonna reevaluate but i gave it a [__]
year
and nothing happened they still got a
little [__] weird smell to them i
love smelling the powder oh my god it
smells like mildew
and tortilla chips rolled up together
you roll them in a joint like the one
night i put them in a joint oh my god
it's like eating [__] mushrooms you
start seeing things and [__] it's better
than mushrooms because the mushrooms you
end up with [__] diarrhea i'm just
keys kidding yeah i don't put my [__]
toenail dust in the joint anyway
i had a great [__] weekend friday
last week was
crazy because my daughter's at school
thursday and friday when that happens
the house is up in arms because we got
to do [__] with her so i take it to the
gym i'm in charge of taking her to the
gym hanging out with her in the morning
and then [__] uh you know my wife
takes her in the afternoon and i do what
i have to do you know the [__] around
the house
emails torturing people
but it was funny friday you know the ufc
was in town i knew i would hear from
rogan
and friday afternoon he called he goes
do you want to come to the weigh-in i
got my hands i had to go to i had to run
errands last week and [__] go to
hoboken and do a bunch of [__]
but
i uh
said to him listen i'm gonna be home and
[__] he goes do you want to shoot pool
whenever joe comes to town he likes to
shoot pool
and he shoots pool like 20 minutes from
my [__] house when he came
to do madison square garden last time he
came
and they called me when they were at
least at uh new brunswick
at uh the steakhouse there and they
stopped by to see uh what's his name but
they called me like twice that night and
had people over the house had kids over
the house i couldn't meet him so when he
called this friday he goes do you want
to go to the weigh-ins whatever i can't
make it up there by five o'clock
but let's do something tonight he goes
well i'm thinking of going to jersey
to shoot some [__] pool uh
why don't we meet up then i go well i
got a problem tonight
my daughter was going my wife was going
to [__] bingo
and i got the
the kid you know my daughter was going
to bingo with two other
moms on the corner they bought a table
and [__] and i was like you know i can't
my wife was like do you want me to bring
home the car so you could go out i'm
like listen
this is your night out go enjoy yourself
i'll work around it i'll deal with rogue
and i don't know what he's going to want
to do or what time he's going to come so
he called me back and he goes listen we
finished the weigh-in i was at dinner
with my daughter and a couple other kids
and their parents and we were just
talking [__]
and joe called and he goes i'm coming to
shoe pool but i really want to [__]
eat something
let's get a bite to eat i said why [__]
around
now i know
that
i know what type of food this
[__] likes yeah he likes wild
ass food
and he likes states and [__] but he
likes good [__] food like he likes
good food you know so i go listen just
meet me at el nido
and i sent him a link to the [__]
website and
i go you know no expectations if you
want to go go i got a couple other
restaurants you'd go to down here but we
could also go to new brunswick you know
if you go to new brunswick i can't meet
you because i got mercy
so he hit me back and he goes let's
[__] he goes i went online from
neither holy [__] let's go
i got all right i'll meet you there
we kept going back and forth he's
running late there's a lot of traffic
going out of new york city
and sure enough i got home from dinner
me and her were doing some [__] around
the house and
joe called and he goes i'll be there in
five minutes
i jumped in the [__] car el nido's
what [__] a couple minutes from my
house
i went down there it was great to see
him uh it was great to see the owner of
the joint we had a nice talk
i went in i sat with mercy mercy talked
to joe for a little while and it was
[__] hysterical because you know
people at the restaurant were looking at
joe and [__] my daughter doesn't know
who joe rogan is and she doesn't give a
[__] she knows joe she's met you a few
times
but she doesn't give a [__] at the end
of the day everybody's the same guy you
know
so it's funny every time my daughter got
up people would say something to her
like she would go to the bathroom or
whatever i would walk her
and they would go oh you're a lucky girl
or whatever she didn't know if you're
lucky for what i'm sitting with [__]
idiots
so she's over there with a little phone
watching us and listening to his talk
and one thing led to the [__] other
and we got the [__] out of there
uh i was i left it that i was gonna meet
joe later on to shoot pool my wife got
home early but my wife didn't get home
really i didn't want to rush it
but here's the [__] kinker of the
night
we get home and her and i are watching
some [__] cooking shows she loves
that
dives drives and automobiles and [__]
the guy fieri she loves guy fieri and
she loves bobby flay
so guy fieri's talking to some indian
guy the guy's got an indian restaurant
in [__]
wisconsin or milwaukee or something like
the best indian restaurant up there
and he's talking to him the guy goes the
guy didn't pronounce it right
the indian guy says you need to put
brogan in it
something like that he goes
guy fieri didn't know what he was
talking about he didn't understand them
right the guy's got a hindu accent he
goes you need to put the brilliant in it
or something like that and the guy goes
and guy fieri goes
joe rogan what's he got to do with it
and they showed a picture of joe rogan
and my daughter goes hey wait a minute
we were just at the restaurant with that
guy
who the [__] and she didn't say who the
[__] is that she goes who is he like oh
mercy he's my friend he's a comedian i
try to tell you that on the way down
there we did comedy for 23 years
he put my [__] career on the map with
his podcast you know the whole thing
she's like wow oh my god she didn't
[__] know so i had a show and then i
reminded
we had a picture from when we she went
to joe's house and went swimming she was
like a little baby with joe and his
daughters and we showed her she's like i
don't remember that well you shouldn't
you we're [__] a year old you know oh
maybe you never know with her
so uh
we left it at that saturday
i was thinking of going to the [__]
ufc
i really wanted to go i thought it was a
good fight
i thought it was a great card and uh
frank he was fighting frankie
i'm thinking of doing this podcast this
week um
it's been long overdue we've been going
back and forth for [__] close to a
year
and uh
berkeley was in town i would have loved
to seen him
so bert hit me up saturday and he said
he was going to be at the garden all
these guys with the guard and i was
thinking of going you know i when joe
was here that night i asked him if he
had an extra chicken he goes he would
get me in
but there was one dilemma that i [__]
the fight the main card started at ten
o'clock
holy [__]
10 o'clock
you know i don't know what time i would
have got out of there
i would have driven you know i don't
give a [__] about driving and [__] like
that but
at the same time i didn't there's a
train and the train leaves at 37 minutes
after the hour so there's one at 12 37
there's one at 137 so i was like worst
case scenario the fight ends at [__]
12 12 30.
if i catch the 1 30 train that won't get
me home till three [__] am by the
time i get in
drink my tea go to bed it's [__] four
in the morning i can't
i don't want to do that i don't think i
can handle that so i invited one of my
friends over he lives around the corner
um
i could tell he was struggling this last
week he was calling me a few days to do
something every time he called me i was
doing something with my family so i said
listen
i'm buying a fight tonight
they started 10
you know a couple people invited me over
to their home like a dear friend of mine
said do you want to come over and watch
the fights and i'm like if they started
at seven i would go over there like
usually some nights of the week jimmy
will invite me over to his house to
watch like monday night football or
i'll go over to the watch like the world
series or the thursday night game of the
week but let me tell you something once
9 30 comes i'm out of there
because he's got a son
he's got a kid
you've have somebody come to your house
mike you got two kids like if i come to
you
yeah if i come over tomorrow and i go
mike do you mind if i watch the game
i think in your back of your mind you're
gonna go well the game starts at seven
the game ends up like at 11.
joe's probably gonna leave it like 9 30
quarter to 10. you know once your kid
looks and he goes daddy i'm kind of
tired and once they start getting like
you know uh fidgety or [__] like that
it's time for you to [__] leave so
whenever i go to jimmy's house you know
i get there on time we crack some jokes
we watch a few innings or a few [__]
i watch the first quarter i'll watch it
till halftime but once this kid goes to
[__] sleep i like start to get asleep
9 30 i get up and i get the [__] out of
that the same with this guy that invited
me last night if i go over there at
seven yeah we we watch the prelims the
[__] main card don't start till 10
that means at 12 o'clock he's looking at
me kind of tired you know people look at
you tired maybe he doesn't want you to
leave but in my mind i gotta [__]
leave so now i gotta come over here mr
usman fight and [__]
get it i gotta spend the [__] eighty
dollars because i couldn't stay over
there late i said [__] it i just get it
in my house
i don't want to be at somebody's house
at 10 30 at night he's got two kids his
wife's gonna come downstairs and go what
the [__] you guys are still here so i
said [__] it i just rented it my buddy
came over as a matter of fact what did i
tell you my buddy left after the [__]
chinese chick fought you know
it's 11 30 12 o'clock in [__] night
he was like i gotta get up and do [__]
tomorrow so i pretty much watched the
usman fight by myself i went over i got
a box a little ice cream sundaes from
carvel the pre-made ones you know they
like little tiny like [__] 10 points
10 one watching points
i had stuffed shells i invited them over
you know he drank beer i brought down
the beers i had from the upstairs
refrigerator i think i got like four
[__] beers in this house each one is
different that's the most embarrassing
thing in the world
i got like a heineken i got a heineken
light i got like a bud light and there's
like some other one snowbird or some
[__] that somebody brought over here
he was laughing my buddy goes man when
you say you don't drink
you [__] mean it what the [__] you
know i go no i don't [__] drink so
it turned out to be great it was great
to see joe you know
when i was sitting there across from him
i go [__] this is like
23 years we've been doing this you know
going to dinners and [__]
i hadn't seen him in close to a year the
last time i saw him was uh
like july 20th when i did the podcast
and i left august 19th
you know it was funny i was thinking
about mike uh
over the weekend well when i was talking
to joe
joe said where's mike i go mike's at
home i forgot that mike was working
friday night and he goes call mike see
if he wants to come i go mike lives two
hours from here you know
by the time he gets up here he'll come
up here just to go to sleep
but it was funny that night when i was
driving home
i was thinking about mike and i go i
remember when mike called me like three
years ago
and you said you know what i'm thinking
i'm moving that way
and i said to you
don't
because there's nothing going on out
here and you were like what do you mean
there's podcasts is like a listen trust
me i'm telling you
there's nothing going on here and that's
when i thought about it like
i did that podcast with joe and i was
still in l.a for a month
i didn't see
joe people had
this wrong idea of what was going on in
l.a
we would not
like i would see my friends at the
comedy store
this is why i was it wasn't that i was
frustrated
is that i was ready for a change
it wasn't that i would see my friends at
the comedy store from theo to [__]
lead
to to bert to joe i always saw him at
the store
what got to me was we weren't doing
things like we were doing them when i
first got to l.a
you know that's what was starting to
bother me it's not
theo's fault it's not josh wolfe's fault
it's not joe rogan's fault
it's life you know people got lives i
you know i always had a girlfriend but i
ended up getting you know when you when
you're first dating your girlfriend when
you're doing comedy
it's a very light thing nobody's in love
nobody wants to fall in love
you don't know what's going to happen
but then as you go on
you know we just got caught up in our
lives you know i the listen i live
i lived maybe three blocks from berk
and today i live
two blocks from jim florentine
i see jim florentine
20 times more
than i was seeing bert not because jim
is a better guy than bird or
bert was never around
bert was always busy doing podcasts he
had his kids blah blah blah with jimmy i
see jimmy at the gym i see jimmy at the
supermarket
i see jimmy at
sports functions i see jimmy at family
affairs
so that's why i needed i needed a couple
[__] jimmies
i needed a couple friends in my life i
wasn't seeing anybody how weird is that
i did the podcast on the 18th 19th of
july
but i didn't see rogan again until
[__] last friday
that's just to let you know what i was
trying to explain to you guys
why i didn't want to be a part of that
no more i wasn't seeing anybody what
good is to have tom segura i mean dean
del rey lived
seven minutes from me
and i saw dean
but i didn't see dean
as much as i saw jimmy
so it was like
this has been a big [__] change like
this is just to let you know that in l.a
we not had our hands
loaded at all times i remember my nephew
coming out
i don't know how many times i had people
visit me and it was like
guys i'm doing this i'm doing this i
can't really see you
like i can't see you too he's like i
don't
you know if you get off a plane i want
to see you today
i want to see you tonight you know
that's the way we are i wouldn't see my
nephew for three or four [__] days
and he'd come visit me i wouldn't see my
niece for three or four [__] days
that's not the problem anymore
now i see people now and that's what
that's the reason why i had to get out
of l.a that was it i just wasn't
for so many people that lived so close
together
i wasn't seeing anybody
i wasn't seeing anybody when i got to
l.a
in 97
you know from 97
to 2003 we were like a [__] family
we were together all day and it makes
sense
it makes sense when joe started doing
news radio uh once joe started doing uh
fear factor
once ralphie started hitting
with the [__] uh
you know with the road after last comic
standing mitch hedberg moved away doug
stanhope moved away
josh wolfe got busy with his stuff that
little pack that little bond that we had
put together in the beginning was kind
of gone
you know we were all doing our own
things i used to see josh
eight times a day i went from saying
josh wolf eight times a day they're not
saying [__] josh at all except
at the [__] comedy store
so
yeah the comedy store brought us
together but
i wanted that little life thing i wanted
to do dinners
i wanted our families to interact i
wanted
to have more barbecues with each other
and that just wasn't happening it's not
their fault i'm not mad at anybody for
that we just got too [__] busy
and we forgot about what was important
that's it and now
i brought all that back up to the
forefront
the interactions the
the little parties you know
i was telling people i feel a lot better
now because i got into my groove i got
into a groove that works for me
you know i had to get up off my ass for
a while i was struggling i struggled for
a [__]
a year i've never
struggled for a [__] year it's been
like two or three months or whatever
so this was a [__] eye-opening
experience for me but
i'm happy i made the journey and i'm
happy
you guys made the journey with me i know
a lot of a lot of people started
watching this podcast going he's not the
same guy and i wasn't and i wasn't i was
in a [__] cocoon
i was changing why you guys were
watching me i was like a butterfly that
puts the [__] cocoon inside you're
like what the [__] going on in that
cocoon that's what was going inside i
was getting i was adjusting myself to my
new [__] lifestyle and it's great i'm
loving what i'm doing and a lot of
people like even joe is like you don't
miss stand up and i'm like no
i don't miss stand up and i don't miss
nothing that comes with it
i don't miss that lifestyle
i'm i'm excited about
2022 i am so [__] excited
about next year this year's done already
it's over we're two weeks away from
thanksgiving in about two weeks the mind
goes somewhere else as a matter of fact
people are already in the christmas
spirit because they don't even know if
the supply the supply chain is gonna
bring them enough [__] for [__]
christmas this year we don't [__]
know my wife said she went shopping on
friday and there were people all over
the mall she goes and there wasn't no
[__] kids people are out already
so i'm advising you [__] right
now i advise you last year with the
pandemic
to [__] start shopping now get it out
of the way don't call me on the 24th
going joey i couldn't get that
sweatshirt hey
i [__] told you shit's not around my
wife went to costco a couple weeks ago
there was no toilet paper
there was no [__] toilet paper she
had to go to like [__]
uh
the cousin the cvs walgreens walgreens
walgreens she had to go like [__]
walgreens
this uh
sunday morning i woke up
and
you know we they set the [__] clock
back
so you woke up it was like [__] nine
o'clock but it's really 8 15 to catch
meow and i said let me get the [__] out
of bed i got to figure out what the [__]
to do i got up
talked to my wife had my coffee went
outside did my
you know my grateful thing five things
i'm grateful for today
and i came downstairs to the
basement to
open up the computer
see what the [__] happened in the world
the night before
and uh
we'll talk about astro world in a second
a buddy of mine lisa messina dear friend
of mine
sent me two great [__] pictures that
i had actually sit there and go what the
[__]
and i'll show these to you now i sent
them to mike so you can put it up
for the podcast just so you guys could
see
jesus christ
this [__] uh
if you guys are looking for a job
seriously just send a [__] resume
to ziprecruiter
ziprecruiter has not stopped sending me
[__] job
things and listen my resume is [__]
my resume is [__] one credit like i
did it in 10 minutes and i just sent it
to him on the phone and i'm getting all
these job offers if you guys are looking
if you're seriously looking for a
[__] new career
and you're seriously looking to [__]
change your life
it's right in front of you with covet
this is opened up listen man in chaos
there's great opportunity sometimes
and right now there are some
opportunities out there that even alms
like holy [__]
that's a hundred
thousand dollar a year job
that that [__] that used to be 50 grand
now they're giving you insurance they're
giving you everything to show up at that
job scholarship they'll give you a kid a
scholarship they'll change his [__]
diapers you know they're not [__]
around anymore so if you're looking to
really step up your life and your
[__] game i would put a resume
together and see where you get and start
lying who gives a [__] that they're
[__] hiring up right now you can hire
up who gives a [__] you'll learn why
you're doing it who gives a frenchman's
[__] go for it i would i would if i
could oh my god i've seen some [__]
tremendous jobs lately there's some
podcast jobs there's some broadcasting
[__] jobs there's some work
20 years ago i would have dreamed of
those [__] jobs and right now they're
like yeah they're there right now
the boys club [__] outreach director
i mean there's tons of [__] work so
if you're seriously [__] looking for
a career and a job now is the time to
[__] do it but we're talking about
this picture
i'll show it to you but you're not gonna
see [__] on here i mean
it's a
43 year old [__] picture what do you
think you're gonna [__] see here they
gotta tighten this up but it's a picture
of me
on my right it's david ruiz and this kid
orlando salcedo that was one of the
funniest [__] i ever met in my
life and on my left side you got louis
hernandez aka louisa
and you got dominic special god rest his
soul
great picture of us on the eighth grade
[__] trip
that's by callahan's we got to go to
callahan's up in fort lee [__] i
don't know if you've ever been to
cantons they got great hot dogs
foot long [__] savages they got
tremendous charcoal burgers but here's
the kick are you ready
they got you on tap
they used to don't quote me on that they
used to
and then the other picture they sent me
is me
my eighth grade teacher walla lindsey
and the man of steel on my left mr
anthony balzano got rested so my [__]
brother from a different mother
this picture mr [__] uh it was yeah
like i said this
this dude here wally lindsay got 13
years
he got [__] for racketeering
uh attempted murder he was my eighth
grade teacher and the mayor of [__]
weehawk and look that nail look that
[__] name up mayor
wally
w-a-l-l-y
lindsay l-i-n-d-s-e-y
he was a good he's a good [__]
good teacher we had a good time with him
let me tell you something i told you
guys about seven months ago that all my
friends that i'm coming back here to the
guys from grammar school
are starting to raise their hand
remember i told you that i've been
talking
and i got to be honest these guys
louis
hernandez david ruiz
lucio fernandez who's a commissioner up
in union city
lisa messina
there's these certain kids i grew up
with
that we built this unbreakable [__]
bond if if
if you came to me and say joey how do i
build a bond with somebody
i'm like i have no [__] idea how do
you build a bond with somebody
you i don't know you become part of
their life you run with them i don't
[__] know
i'm blown away i thought i had bonds
with other people
you know from colorado or
people that i did comedy with out of all
the groups that i've been around the
criminals the comics the [__]
invics
the hippies in boulder
you know i didn't know i didn't know who
i created bond with
and this blew me the [__] away and when
i looked at that picture of us five
saucedo ruiz
you have no idea how tight we were
we were all so [__] tight
from the sixth grade i gotta be honest
with you it just wasn't that us five in
that picture
there had to be 15 of us
and we breathed for one another you know
my bond with anthony balzano and it's
still there he may be dead but i feel
anthony
i talk to anthony once a week i i
look at his picture and i tell him to
give me strength and i miss him
you know i like the candle for those
idiots on monday all of them dominic
anthony my mother
i light a candle from guys i put a
little shot of [__] uh
rum from my friends at the
on the uh
family altar there you know and i think
of them a lot they're gone and i've come
across a lot of people
in my life people in boulder people in
aspen people and snowmass
and i'll tell you what man these guys
are [__] tied into me it was funny
because i got two i woke i woke up to
two text messages i woke up to lisa
sending me those two pictures and i woke
up to dominic's sister
asking me if i was going to the mckinley
reunion
mckinley is the grammar school we went
to
there's uh seven grammar schools in the
north bergen area
mckinley was one of them mckinley isn't
the most uh
best area in the world mckinley area
mckinley franklin lincoln we were all
considered like the duds
but we [__] shocked those
[__] you know
so they're having a mckinley reunion
like on the 18th or the 17th i think
it's the 18th
it's uh
what is it 88
wow 21
the 18th is 33 years from when i
kidnapped ken bella so
i have a reason to [__] celebrate it
was 33 years ago so i'm gonna go out
with them
for the mckinley reunion have a good
time and just uh
see some old friends it's good for the
[__] soul you know you
you gotta see some people right before
the holidays
i think it'll be great you know
i think i'm gonna invite wally lindsay
he's got to be about 60 now
give him a call make him come out you
know we had a lot of good [__] times
but
to answer your question i thought about
how come we had bonds like this with
these guys
i thought about it all day yes you know
last night
and it's got to be because of what we
went through together as kids you know
we lost anthony
years later we lost dominic
but we weren't just friends at that age
for us being 13
i knew what my friends were like at 13.
i know my friends are like now
the difference i had with these friends
it was the beginning of me caring about
friends
it was the first time that
we had each other's [__] backs me and
these
15 kids i mean
it's going to be great to see them
i hope they start to read and early
because we're not gonna get out of there
till like six in the morning because
there's so many [__] stories there's
so many things
that happen between us like as kids and
we were there for one another deaths
you know fights family issues you know a
lot of these kids had family issues
growing up
and you see what happened when my mother
died all these people in north bergen
opened their
homes to me the same thing when we were
[__] kids with these guys we like i
said if you didn't have money we had it
you know this guy his mother hit him
we'd [__]
talk him off the ledge you know this
guy's father left the house
and didn't come back one day went out
for a pack of cigarettes and then come
back you know
we had him you know it was so weird that
at that age
at that young age we had each other we
let each other know
it was gonna be all right you know for
me my stepfather moved out my mother got
arrested
my mother lost a [__] ball when i was
in the eighth grade all these things
didn't matter
these guys are my friends through
[__] thick and thin you know
and it's really [__] it's a great
feeling
and i tell you this is a great feeling
it's like
knowing
that degree worked or knowing that
you know your kid's gonna be okay or
knowing that you know
it's all gonna work out knowing that
these guys still think about me
40 years after grammar school
that we all talk 40 years up this is not
high school i got my high school friends
they're great i love them to death
this is grammar school the thought that
till this [__] 40 i graduated grammar
school in 1978
to think that we were all gonna keep in
[__] touch
and have the same love we had for each
other
when we were in the eighth and seventh
grades together we would because we all
played cyo ball together we were on
mckinley together we went to the movies
together we went to get sandwiches
together we smoked pot together
we travel i remember still walking up
the hill with these guys
we would be walking up the hill and
there would be three circles of us
of maybe 10 people walking up the hill
nobody disagreeing
nobody arguing everybody drank miller
light you know there was no i remember
they would always order miller light
like and if you ever opened up miller
and sniffed the [__] bottle it smells
like 10 dead dicks i [__] hated
miller but all these things seeing these
guys
bring me back and to me this is my
strength
this is where i [__]
this is where i excel
you know i'm [__] horrible at a lot
of things i'm not good
i can't fix a car i'm terrible at jiu
jitsu you know i'm terrible at a lot of
things but one thing i'm really good at
is cultivating my friendships because i
didn't have a family
you know
your friends are everything
you
friends are your wealth your
relationships are your wealth
when you have great friends you're a
wealthy [__] man when you have a
great family you're a wealthy [__]
man i have no family
but god has given me a pseudo family
and it took me all the way to 58 and i'm
very proud of that
and especially today that it's my
mother's 42
year death anniversary whatever hey [__]
it i'm fine
she's gone i've grown up
everything happens for a reason without
her this happened to her 42 years ago i
wouldn't be here if she lived i would
have lived to be a [__] soft momo so
i'm glad it all turned out the way it is
i'm excited about november 17th the
reunion with these guys
i have no idea what we talked about
today but i don't give a [__] it's
monday morning [__] it's a
beautiful day to be alive and we're here
we made it through another week and
we're gonna make it through this
[__] week believe it or not
it's november the [__] eighth we got
two more months left in the year and
then it's 2022 and it's a whole new
perspective for us
it's a whole new outlook for us a lot of
great things are going to be happening
in 2022. i hope you guys are as excited
as i am because uh we've been eating
[__] for [__] 20 months it's time to
bust out of this [__] i love you
[__] have a great [__] day
enjoy the [__] day it's phenomenal
and i'll see you guys wednesday morning
tip top [__] magoo
ready to go i love you guys don't forget
laughing gas at the ice cream shop
and i'll see you [__] wednesday
tip top magoo i love you [__]
and now
for a word for my [__] sponsor
jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you
for listening to the joint today i know
it wasn't the best one but what are you
gonna do at least we're [__] talking
it's peace of mind i'm letting you know
where i'm [__] at the joint is
brought to you by blue chew listen for
two years i've been talking about blue
chew and how great it is how easy it is
stop [__] crying and listen up
blue chew is gonna make your dick look
[__] beautiful blue chew is an online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis at a
fraction of the cost you could take it
anytime day and night
i would suggest you have something in
your stomach you want your dick to get
hard you're about to sling
you're going to get all sweaty you want
to be prepared let me tell you something
the process is simple for bluetooth all
you got to do is sign up
at bluetooth.com talk to one of the
licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
the best part is it's all online no
doctor's office no pharmacy
no judgment it ships right to your
[__] door and a discreet
package the mailman don't know dick
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they're way cheaper than a pharmacy
listen i'm not saying that you have vd
everybody's stroking you with e.d what
i'm trying to give you is extra
confidence
the confidence to sling dick the
confidence you're gonna go in there last
and tear her up and she's gonna call you
back going no moss [__] sucker
if you could benefit from this extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help and they got a
special deal for you you try blue chew
free with promo code joey just five
dollars for shipping that's free where i
come from that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month
free and as always i want to thank
bluetooth for sponsoring the joint
the joint is also brought to you one of
my favorite
companies of all time on it i love them
i love what they do the videos the
workouts
jesus christ just go to honor.com
take a look at what they're doing there
you haven't visited the website in a
while between the new mood the shroom
tech the shrimptech immune the
emt oil i mean they got so many great
supplements but me you know i'm an alpha
brain
rider diet type of [__] the
black label
oh my god the mental focus is gonna be
[__] tremendous for you it's helped
me man it's been great so what you get
you dream in color you're gonna have a
good time alpha brain comes in a drink
powder
pills
they're phenomenal all i want you to do
is go to on it and take a look this
makes a great christmas present and if
they don't like the alpha brain they
could they could keep it and you could
still get your money back so
that's a company i believe and a company
with a guarantee like that go to
honor.com right now
preston church joey
and get 10 percent off your first order
delivered right to your [__]
crib
the joint is also brought to you by
draftking sportsbook listen you know how
much i love these [__] whether
it's the casino whether it's
the pro football the ufc they got you
covered if you want to make a bet okay
nhl season is underway and draftking
sportsbook has an unbelievable offer to
celebrate the greatest sport on ice but
one dollar
on any nhl game and win a hundred
dollars in free bets
if either team scores a goal
this week florida's coming up to [__]
see the jersey devils you know i'm
betting now now guys listen like i said
draftkings is not just about a sports
betting with a bunch of [__] jerk off
they got a tremendous what they do is
tremendous they're reliable they're safe
and they got the best sports book in the
country they're the
the official sports betting partner of
the nhl nba
[__] major league baseball ufc these
guys got you covered they up to the line
minutes they got live betting and same
game paulie's
and if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
draftkings won't leave you empty-handed
guys
they're giving away huge cash prizes on
the draftkings daily daily fantasy
sports contest if you're a fantasy guy
draftkings is the [__] best they're
giving all new customers a free shot at
a million dollars in total prizes with
their first deposit just enter code joey
when you sign up draw down a dollar on
any fantasy or nhl game and with a
hundred dollars in free bets draftkings
are safe secure reliable you can
withdraw your cash whenever you want
they don't control you guys draftkings
is tremendous take it from me the casino
is great if you're bored you could play
blackjack for a dollar they got
blackjack specials listen just sign up
use promo code joey and go have a great
[__] time you got to be 21 old in new
jersey indiana pa only new customers
only okay minimum five hour deposit with
a dollar wager and it's only one deal
per customer don't be cute and try to do
it for the nhl nba i'll [__] stab you
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gammon palm i want you to take care of
it and draftkings want you to take care
of it so call 1-800 gambler
but if you're straight head to
draftkings and let's make some
[__] guitars but it all starts
with you downloading the draftking
sportsbook app today or the sport the
draftkings daily fantasy app today i
want to thank bluechu i want to thank
hannah and i want to thank draftkings
for having all back today but most
importantly i want to thank you
[__] savages for always being
here i love you have a great week and
stay black
we'll be back wednesday
tip top [__] magoo i love you
[__]
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
you